how many books do i read a month i don't
i don't track the number of books i
don't think it's a relevant metric at
all uh if you read one amazing book a
year that changes your life then that's
all it takes
books read is just a vanity metric
number of words read is a vanity metric
um
somebody on twitter i think it was ella
cerda said i would rather
read the hundred top books than read a
lot of books and i think that's right i
skin in the game actually it's the
second time i've sort of read it i read
about it about halfway through the first
time then i let it sit for a while then
i went through it again
and now i'm sort of reviewing it one
more time
so i i
forget about number of books read
books reading books is completely
a personal
um experience it's a single player game
as i've said before
so there's no point in trying to
do book reading for other people in fact
sharing books in that sense
is bad
sharing what books you're reading is bad
because it forces you to pretend like
you're reading more than you are or
you're reading smarter than you are
um yeah how does one know uh which of
the top 100 books so that's why you read
more than 100 books because you skim
very very quickly
to find the ones that grab you and are
important and interesting for you and
then you stick to those and you go
really deep there's exploration
and there's
exploitation sorry the camera slipped
there's exploration there's exploitation
so you explore
a lot of books
until you
until you
decide that there's something there to
exploit
yes reading is a journey to find the
great books for you that's correct
how to get smarter just
read a lot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
do
do
you